me
[音楽]
私は今から農業の未来について話をします
もともと私に11年間市場でセリ人をしていました
皆さん市場ってどんな所か知っていますか
簡単に言うと農産品をたくさん仕入れてスーパーさあみたいなとこにたくさんある
まぁこんな感じですちょっとざっくり水ですけど
1日の売り上げが多く大きい値なんですね
1パックではなくてそうだなこの会場の100倍ぐらいの面積が市場の面積でこれが
毎日農産品で取引されるくらいのスケールの大きなところがこれ市場です
そこで私は荷物をさばいていたんです毎日
でも農産引いて農家さんの努力の賜物なんですね
さっき寄った荷物た爆これっていけないことだと思うんですよ
賜物なんですよね
だから得る農産品と言わない
過去の私はなんて必要な販売方法してたんだなってすごい今反省しています
そしてまた当時の私は
全国の産地にも出向いていましたそこで感じたことがあるんです
農家さん毎年減ってねえかってね
実際減ってるんですよこれ見てくださいめちゃくちゃ減っている
ピークの農家さんが多かった時に比べるとなんと7割減ってるんです
農家さんが減るので農産品が減るのでということで私たち一番の業界もめーちゃくちゃ
同じように売り上げが減ったです
とんでもない期間です
農業が衰退する=市場協会もし衰退して売り上げがなくなるんですよ
仕事がなくなるかもしれないですよねってこれ神経悩んだんですよ
そこでこの業界の衰退をどうすれば食い止めれるんだろう
どうすればこれ未来に繋がるんだろうってチェックを真剣に考えた
そこで私はこうやったんです根本的な解決になるための手段を考え始め
ざっくり言うと今の流れてこんな感じです農家さんが作った農産品が
卸売業者に流れるそれがスーパーさんに流れて消費者の皆さんの手に届く
まあこういう流れなんですね
ということはここに何か問題があるっていうふうに私は考えた
もう少し深掘りしてみましょう
農家さんは今もっている田んぼや畑やハウスでいつ何を作ろうって自ら考えて生産して
いるんです
でできたのを3品を卸売業者さんに頑張って高く売ってねってお願いする販売がいまし
終了なんですこれを委託販売と言います
受けた側は痛くよは任せられて売るので市場のセリなどは相場で売るんですね
要は農家さんが作った思いや品質で価格を決定するのがメインではなくてですね
相場で値段が付くんですよ
どういうことかというと量が多いと安い
少ないとたかえこれが相場なんですね
そうそう何が起きるかって
価格が不安定なんです当然経営が不安定になる
最悪売れないなんて可能性すらあるんですよ
まあここがよは問題点なんですねこれじゃいけない
そこで南矢田までめっちゃくちゃ考えたんですねどうすればこれ解決できるかなーって
枚目ちゃった
先に売れ酒を決めちゃえばいいってめちゃくちゃシンプルなんです
これなんでできるかというと私は長く市場にいたんです
今も中や腰くれるビッグバイヤーの流通業者さんがいっぱいいるんですよ
そこで結構めんどくさい性格でしてしつこく聞いたんです
何をいい条件で作ればた抱えとってくれるんだってね
cisco 9神経に聞いたんでまあ結構みんな答えてくれたんですよいやいやです
けど要はそういう答えがあったんです
くるの山品品質価格ここで決まりました
そこで私は農家さんに求められた農産品を作ってもらうようにお願いするようにしまし
た
そして私がお願い車農産品などで農家さんの農産品私が全力変えておりますそして私も
バイヤーさんからお願いされた農産品が目の前にあるのでそれを全量を販売するという
ことを
今実際やっています
ああああああ
これによって農家さんは本当にこれってしっかり売り切ってくれるかなとかいくらで
売れるんだろうとか売れないなんてことないようなみたいなハントの不安から解消さ
れるようなことが今私のこのことで実現するようになったんです
要は出口を先に決めたんですこれが非常に重要だけどシンプルでも難しいけど私なる今
できている
けどこれだけでアンばあのなかなかうまくいかなかったんですよ
求められる品質量安定生産というその栽培技術ってすごいハードルが高いことに気づき
ました
農家さんがなかなか増えないとかやめてしまう理由が経営が不安定って言ってっていう
ものともう一つ
栽培技術が凄い難しいということが挙げられます
聞いたことありませんか匠の技術って
なんとなくて言ったら怒られますけど知識と経験と勘から得られるものが匠の技術
これってすごい長い年月がかかるんですよ
ひょっとしたらですねその栽培いしている品目とか
場所が変わると全く使い物にならないっていう技術でもあるんですよ
でもそれだと私は求められているも品質と農産品が決まっているのでうまく流通させ
ないと怒られてしまうんですそこで栽培技術の確立
が急務になったんです
そして3年間試行錯誤の結果こんな技術を確立しました
みてくださいロックウールと言いました工業製品よく
住宅などの壁の断熱材で使われる材質ですサイズが6センチかける6cm ちゃ小さい
んですよ
要は猫を自作したんです
トマトってよくストレスをかけるとおいしくなるって言える農産品です
を実際そう
匠の農家さんはほとんど方が土で作りますね
で匠の技術で大きな根っこをコントロールしてより良い農産やトマトを作る技術がある
けどさっき説明しました
この匠の技術うまく手に入らないんですそこで逆のことをやったんですねこう小さく
することによってコントロール
いる栽培技術ということに思いついてこの確率を私はしたんです
こっから先本当はあんまり言いたくない
じゃあその肝はない水やりだったんです
水やりをコントロールする栽培技術です
これをコンピューター制御することに成功したんです
ただコンピューターで制御することが正解じゃないんですよ
何が正解能楽の理論に基づいてコンピューター制御することが非常に重要だということ
です
なぜかって匠の技術経験と勘が重要ですね
それを脳学の理論ならば論破出来るだろうと私は考えたんです
しかも難しい技術の継承というハードルを上げている農業の現場
この技術を使えばハードルが避けられるだろうというふうにも考えたからこれを私は
取り入れた
実際
トマトは夏場この暑い時期ってうまく作れないんですよ
ただ私が作ったこの技術で今結構作れることに成功しています
それはなぜかというとこの技術を使うことのこの栽培のマニュアル化に成功したから
です
実際私のグループ会社の農業未経験の若者たちがこのマニュアルによって一年中高品質
でめちゃくちゃ美味しいトマトに作ることに成功しています
これリアルです
そしてですねただそれだけじゃあんまりインパクトがなくて
高額なお金をかけたハウスではなくて私がやっているのは農業の井肉ビジネス見たこと
言われるんですけども
安い中古ハウスのビニールハウスを活用してこれを実現したんです
まあ結構公務して喋ってるんですけどね多分皆さんは館内でこれ農家さんとか農業科学
科ではせるととんでもない技術革新なんですね
ちょっとせません自己満足で喋ってます
で今後このマニュアルをですね農業を始めたいという農業未経験の方や今栽培うまく
出来ないって悩んでる方に提供していく
これでやっと私が考えた流通のこの新しい品質基準から求められる仕組みが農産品が
加工できるのでやったねできたなと思ったんですよ
甘くないですね世の中ねぇ問題が起きました
クレームなんです
宮地から言った農産品百貨店で高いものをおいしいとお前言ったじゃないかって
買ったら美味しくなかった結構クレームがあったんですよ
これは何かというとか買おうとしている消費者の皆さんがこの求められるトマトとか
農産品今買おうとしているものの品質の基準がよくわかっていないということに私は
気づきました
今喋ってる最中に品質基準
そんなあるやんけって思う人たぶんいる
コレですコレコレポーど
今一般的な基準で投打なんですね
数字が高ければ高いほど甘いって言われる
結構みんなそう思ってるでしょ糖度=甘さでも実はないんです
これ見て下さいこの衝撃的ですよこれ島時計と言われる機械でトマトトレも同じ機械で
同じ時間に測った数値 q 10などを表している
すごい高品質なフルーツトマトが8度以上と言われるのでこの9.7のトマトは
めっちゃくちゃ前
実際食べましためちゃくちゃ美味しかったです
これ酸っぱさの代表格でもあるレモン
普通のスーパーさんで方でもなんでなんなら特別なでもではないみんな甘いでもやって
思ってるでしょ
当然酸っぱいんですよ酸っぱい糖度計なんですよ
同じ時間に同じ機械でこれおかしいと思いませんか
じゃあこの9.7は何かっていうと甘さや酸っぱさなどが合算した数値がただ表されて
いるだけなんです
いまいちわかんないですかねぇ
はいわかんないとよくわかんないねはいはいはいはい
これはですねは明確に甘いとか酸っぱいとかの品質がこの糖度計では表されていないと
いうことなんですよ
ただ行っ農家さんはこの棟の計の数値を基により良いものを作ろうと日々努力されて
いる
私たち卸売業者や消費者の皆さんはこの数値を基に売り返しているのが今の現実なん
です
何度も言いますけども私が新しく作ろうとして流通の仕組みは先に品質基準を決めて
販売価格を決めると言っています
そうそ今の糖度基準といわゆる一般のこの基準だと甘いか酸っぱいがよくわからないの
が今の基準なんですねちょっとまた私クリアまで怒られちゃうんですねこれじゃ困るん
ですよそこで
また考えたんです
でヒラメちゃんですね結構ね
生産者おろ修理業者消費者
共通の新しい品質基準を作ってしまえばこれ
carver できるようなって思ったんですよそこで今開発するのはこれ
ftir センサたくんでしょこれちょっとイメージですイメージ
これ赤外線という光がピッティ当たるんですね
まあ出るんですよそれで糖度じゃなくて甘いとか酸っぱいと狩りコピーみたいな有機物
が図れるセンサーなんです
しかもこれは持ち運びができるように小型化した
センサーになっていて2021年までに完成させる
これ結構小径的な会でしてこれ実は2021年にできるとワールドプレミア生開発の
センサーなんですね
大手道ですよまあいいやまあ病ン
でこれをですね小型化して現場で持ち運びができるようになるので農家さんの現場で
言うとピッと当てるとあこれはの収穫できるよね美味しいよねとか
なんなら1か月くらい前に青い状態のトマト煮ピって光を当てると1か月後にこの
ぐらいの音言われたと元に作らないといけないからこういう栽培をしていこうみたいな
現場ではそのように使えるは栽培技術の向上にすごい
あの関与できるな繊細になるんですよ
で私たち業者や消費者の皆さんは何がメリットがあるかってこれです
さっきの糖度計よくわかんない9.7でしたね
甘いか酸っぱい勝手で本当にでも酸っぱかったですからねはい
でもこのセンサーを使うと明確に甘さや酸っぱさを区別して表示することができる
センサーなんです
じゃあこれがなんですよ買って3回目です私があなたに作ろうとしている
流通の仕組みは品質基準を決めて販売カカオ決めるこの仕組みなんです先ほどの塔だけ
だとよくわからない曖昧な品質基準でしょ
だから困るということでこのセンサー開発をしているんです
そうそう皆さんは狙った好みのトマトとかレモンとか
桃とかが買えるような世の中が今もう少しで目の前に来ている
まあこれが現実です結構楽しみにしていてください
これから私はこの農業界のハードルが高いというこの技術確立
これを私たちのこの技術を使うことで誰でもできる農業の実現をまずさせていくこれを
入口です
そして出口
得るじゃダメなんです売り切らないとダメ
じゃあ通り切るかって言った先に品質と販売価格を決定してしまうのでもう売り切れる
んですね
これで入部袖口が決まった
けど曖昧な品質基準じゃダメです言ったですね
今日数の品質基準がこれは強固につなげる事で一つのサービスになります
これによってこの業界の未来が私は開けるっていうふうに信じています
いつか
農業未経験の若者たちが農業を仕事にする
そんな当たり前の世界観私は作っていきたい
それまでチャレンジを続けます